Andy is in Illinois hi Andy welcome to
the Dave Ramsey Show
thanks Dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
uh about three months ago my wife and I
uh did a 1035 Exchange from our Whole
Life policies into fixed index Universal
policies of 125k each uh we rolled about
7 600 of cash value into those new
policies we're paying about 190 a month
for those uh now I'm having second
thoughts as if if we should have done
that or can we use that money so you did
an exchange to protect the taxes on
seven thousand six hundred dollars and
not even all of it was taxable
yes
yes
what kind of fees did you pay to do that
I didn't pay any fees on it uh I just
got a uh
tax form a tax time just said I had the
income on it that was not taxable so why
would the 7600 be taxable
uh well it's I don't think it's taxable
it's just that's what the cash value
that I moved from the whole yeah
I mean the only reason to do a rollover
of the cash value is if the cash value
is taxable and it almost never is
because your basis in a in a rip-off
whole life policy is the total of the
premiums you've paid in you paid in more
than 7 600 bucks
right so yeah you can close this whole
thing down and have no tax event can't
you
uh yeah I just uh I know you've been uh
talking about the whole life insurance
not a good idea just go with terms so
um no I'm just saying if you wanted to
go that way
and you said okay I'm gonna have some
inexpensive term insurance I'm gonna do
investing of my 7 600 and my hundred and
ninety dollars a month into good
Investments
um you don't have a tax event if you do
that do you
now finally uh concern is the surrender
charges is about six thousand dollars on
the 7600
yes
good Lord
yeah I think I got into something that
maybe I shouldn't have yeah yeah I think
you got screwed you got screwed yeah so
I'm I'm wondering if it's worth taking
that yeah that loss yeah it is to go
forward it is because the problem is is
that the money the it's the 200 a month
that you're losing now
190 bucks a month is going into crap
and you've already established that it's
crap
and yet we're putting more money in it
and so that's that's the downside it's
not the it's not what the 7600 could
become it's what that 2400 a year
is becoming and that turns into money
fast that's a lot of money what do you
make a year
uh our income for the home is 130 000 a
year yeah yeah I thought I thought you
were making good money so really
honestly the truth is at the end of the
day
20 years from today if we set fire in
the middle of your kitchen table to two
thousand four hundred dollars a year and
we set fire in the middle of the kitchen
table seven thousand six hundred dollars
once you still are going to be able to
build wealth
and here's the good news here's the good
news we're only setting fire to one of
them
yeah yeah to free up the other one
right yeah yeah so yeah I mean that
because the problem is is that you're
adding more to an investment that's not
going to do well and has extremely high
fees
okay that's the bigger problem than the
dead gum man I hate it though it it
doesn't turn your stomach to lose that
six grand College things that's the part
that I I understand what you're saying I
bought a rip-off when I was a kid in my
20s that way I learned all this stuff
was I bought a rip-off uh man I got
screwed so bad Northwestern Mutual uh
whole life which is like one of the
worst Whole Life policies out there I
mean it's the worst math on the thing
and I bought the thing and I was dumping
I didn't have a lot of money we were
making like uh 30 40 000 bucks a year
and I'm dumping almost 200 bucks a month
this is a 1980s early right almost 200
bucks a month into this thing but with
the promise it was going to build cash
value and so I was overpaying for my
insurance like
10x 12x in order to build this cash
value and then when I cancel the thing
two years in I had a zero cash value
because for the first three years I keep
all your money as fees and so I had that
same experience of you know getting a
little getting a little throw up in your
mouth you know yeah definitely that's
kind of what I'm going through yeah and
it's more intellectual than it is
actually mathematical but you know the
good news is I I'm 60 now so that's
almost 40 years ago
and um you know what I the good news is
I've never done it again
yeah that's good yeah the memory was
thorough
so and I gotta I talked to a whole bunch
of other people out uh getting ripped
off too so yeah I understand the emotion
is my point and I don't blame you for
that uh good news is six thousand bucks
in your world's not that much money
you're gonna be okay
and it's better to stop doing bad
investing uh from an intellectual
standpoint a mental health standpoint
and a financial standpoint because you
know you're getting screwed you don't
want to just keep putting money in that
pocket there's a hole in the pocket